we're back and we're sitting on stools
tonight we're joined by the cast of what
I consider to be the funniest show on
television Silicon Valley please welcome
Zach woods Thomas Middleditch
[Applause]
while you're wearing the the Pied Piper
jackets everyone on stage is wearing
wool yeah you're an incredibly hot
auditorium wearing wool and those look
awful they look absolutely terrible much
yeah incredibly hot so it I smell like
Ellis Island
now wait you've maintained because
there's an episode of the show obviously
where these jackets debut and they
become chick magnets you have maintained
that you think you look pretty good in
this job I reluctantly liked this jacket
and I know that it's not objectively I
know it's an ugly thing but I love it
just so you know it has everything going
for it rats rat eponymously what number
are we
you'll see you'll note that every letter
is a different color yeah yeah it's
truly it's truly - it's the worst idea
ever
really if you ever had a fantasy about
being a nascar achieved it right yeah
well it's kind of I think well we all
think it was kind of based on our
terrible decision to make jackets for
ourselves in real life we all decided
that it would be a pretty cool thing if
the cast kind of like made jackets for
ourselves they'll warm around the lot we
call ourselves the rude boys a lot on
the studio Sony Pictures lot and we
think the writers were like not on our
watch right put this into the show just
to humiliate you yes such as pasta take
us down a peg now I'm all of ours is
like made out of sweatshirt and this is
like silk line like we made really
shitty ones they made early nice ones
those are gorgeous though
congratulations to all of you